mr breaking news to bring you from
washington d.c in the united states uh
there's an ongoing situation at the
capitol complex
which you'll remember uh from the
january sixth protest by trump
supporters when they stormed the capital
uh there's an ongoing incident there at
the moment and all staff
in the capital buildings and on the
complex there in washington have been
sent a text message that reads
external security threat no entry or
exit
is permitted stay away from exterior
windows
and doors if you're outside seek cover
and that text message has gone to
members of staff at the capitol building
by the police on the complex we don't
have much more information than that
at the moment there are reports of a
large presence of
emergency services um just outside the
entrance that
senators and their staff use to get into
the capital complex
and but at the moment all we're really
sure of is that there has been
an external security threat to the
capital
uh the surrounding streets and the
congressional office buildings in
washington dc and they're asking
everyone who's already inside that
complex
not to go in or out stay away from
exterior windows
and doors and if people are outside to
try and seek
cover we're going to keep you posted on
what's happening there in washington
just about
half past 1 in the afternoon in
washington dc so we'll keep you updated
as and when we get more information stay
with us here on sky news we'll bring you
the latest